the government of ethiopia
says the war is over its law and order
operation
in the region of tigre a complete
success
but the signs of warfare are all around
as we drive south from the regional
capital mckele
sky news is the first media organization
to make this trip
the central government controls the
cities and the highways
and we saw ethiopian troops and soldiers
from its ally
eritrea patrolling roadside towns
but very little is known about this
conflict in communities which lie
off the main road when we stopped on the
outskirts of a place called miwani
local residents told us we were standing
next to a shallow grave
they told us about a massacre on the
23rd of february
when residents were murdered all over
this village
how many people were killed in this
village
[Music]
the soldiers struck in an act of revenge
they said
after a battle in a nearby village and
we were taken to a church yard
to see the graves two or three bodies
per plot
what have you seen one three years
thirteen years
they killed a thirteen-year-old child
yes they can i see in my house
they told for the kid come he says come
and the child go to the shoulder
and kill vegan and again
killed by in this area you saw that yes
i see in my eye
the village looked deserted but in the
following town
we were met by a cacophony of sound
it was market day in gilgit the first
day of trading
since the conflict began and we watched
anxious looking residents
buy or sell a little food
but some here are angry and a
demonstration quickly grew
around us ethiopia's prime minister abi
ahmed
has removed the ruling party the tplf
from power into grey but he hasn't won
the people's hearts
you want us to go to chile
go to chile they said and see what they
have done to us
and as we left they crossed their arms
in a sign of defiance
the remnants of battle littered the road
as we approached
the village of chile obviously something
terrible has has happened here
we've passed dozens of burnt out
military vehicles but it must have been
a fierce battle
and in this sprawling community homes
had been destroyed
and food supplies for humans and animals
had been torched
we met the bayenna family now living
under the open sky
and a story emerged about the past few
weeks
government forces and tplf fighters
clashed here on february 15th
one week later on the 23rd government
soldiers returned
accusing villagers of supporting
relatives of the dead were waiting for
us under the branches of an acacia tree
those unable or unwilling to flee were
slaughtered by government troops they
said
haley selassie kiros said his two
brothers were shot
[Music]
how many people do you think have died
in this community
citing evidence of human rights
violations the un has called
for an investigation and we found one
more docket of evidence
a shallow grave in chile where 18 people
were gunned down say villagers if the
truth
is not revealed thousands more will lose
their lives
john sparks sky news in northern
ethiopia